okay let's talk about the david pakman
show website many of you hundreds of
people emailing in st. David a bunch of
shows are gone from david pakman.com I'm
a member but I can't login at david
pakman.com the website is totally down i
can't access anything here's what
happened we launched the new david
pakman show website in August of 2016 a
little over a year ago and the website
was a hundredfold better than the old
David Pakman show website and it was
absolutely fantastic however what we
didn't account for was that the hosting
recommendation we got from GoDaddy our
now former web host was not the best
recommendation and as the website grew
with more and more members and more and
more content and a bigger and bigger
audience the hosting we had was no
longer able to handle the demands on a
server resources from our website so the
website became very slow the website
would often crash at key times of the
day like after posting new episodes at 4
5 6 p.m. Eastern Time and it was an
absolute and total disaster and this
kind of the straw that broke the camel's
back took place late Monday evening very
early Tuesday morning when some updates
to our web site completely crashed the
site and effectively made it unusable
and we've been delaying and delaying
moving to a better more robust web host
for a while but this made it Pat so that
we just said hey you know what the web
sites already down that's it that's it
this is as good a time as any to go into
what I am calling emergency migration
mode and we did that so the brand new
david pakman.com is now up and running
and thanks to some really great and
speedy work from our tech team including
our great developer katie who took a
break from mom duty with her two kids to
help out as well as our migration
technician who was up until 5:30 a.m.
this morning dealing with this the david
pakman show website is now many times
faster than it ever was and it's so
fantastic and it's not just great for
the audience by the way when the
seit is slow for you it's slow for us as
well and it's not good so we're really
pleased with this a few important things
number one membership if it seems like
your membership isn't working please
fully log out clear your cookies and try
to log back in this will fix 99% of the
issues basically what happened is that
you your browser still has a cookie that
has you logged in to the website but the
website has been moved on to a different
server and so it's creating a conflict
and telling people that they're not
actually members when they are so please
sign out clear cookies signed back in
that will most likely fix the issue if
you signed up over the last 24 to 72
hours it actually is possible that your
membership isn't recognized because
there were there was a period there
where the version the version of the
website that was migrated was about 24
hours old at the time of migration so
some recent members may not be
recognized if that's the case just email
me and I will help you okay and then
also for about three hours the calendar
page was completely down we've set up a
page david pakman.com slash calendar 18
so you can get your david pakman show
calendars for next year you can get them
free with a membership or just the
calendar that page was not working for
about three hours it is back up okay so
if you were trying to get the calendar
yesterday and couldn't that page is back
up great news overall anytime we
transition there's always some growing
pains or some interim period that's not
as good but now we're left with a much
faster website and I think it's great
I mean it's bad news if you prefer
slower unreliable websites yes but good
news good news if you've been sick and
tired of the slowness on the web site
which I have been so that's that all
right